[Music]
hey really odd story out of Spain this
week the city of Barcelona has opened
the world's first brothel made up of sex
dolls that's right a brothel
made of sex dolls so I'm really curious
who would go to this place so we sent
cameras to track down the first client
leaving the sex doll brothel earlier
today take a look fake fake sign sir
excuse me did you just come out of that
sex doll brothel I don't want to talk
about it sir we saw you can go to the
sex doll bralette sir if you could no
pictures damn it I know that I know that
guy it's cute and that's the fakest sign
I've seen in quite a long time welcome
to fake sign Theatre there's nothing
like the old Warner Brothers lot in a
fake sign look at that come on have some
pride in your work people the [ __ ] is
that I I didn't I'm not the one that I
gave it every shot possible that last
one you're the ones that made that turd
of a sign there we go and then just
glued it on to a fake wall come on who
did it was it you GU Moss who slapped it
up on a wall haphazardly Jose is that
you the ultimate craftsman
you literally make your own boots that
you wear to work and you made that sign
oh you proved it
I say volume business who gives a [ __ ]
hey that's a terrible attitude
it's got me this far I get behind stuff
you can say a lot of things about me
Richter oh I do if that's even your name
trust me you need to care my podcast
[Music]
you